[Music]
the women's periods actually sync period
syncing is a real thing super weird
it seems like it would be made up but I
think it has to do with pheromones when
mine like randomly like changes I'm like
oh she's like who's who's switching me
over who's bringing me onto those cycles
why do you pee in herds so usually when
you say like you want to go to the
bathroom with me it's more like I need
to tell you something away from people I
don't pee in her basically you're
probably talking she's so our boobs fun
or annoying boobs are amazing and
everybody loves for small breasted girls
they're probably just more fun and for
bigger breasted girls are probably more
annoying I have a few friends that boobs
hurt their back maybe if you're running
there's a lot of action flopping around
and just kind of hurts you know but then
they can be really fun because it's like
instantaneous sex appeal this size
actually matter yeah
got it does no it does not I think
length isn't as important but I think
girth isn't more important if a guy is
very well-endowed he doesn't try as hard
it's really how you work it so how much
do looks factor into dating very much so
I'm not gonna turn someone down if
they're not my type but like almost
equally is like confidence and how you
carry yourself it's always like an
initial attraction to somebody but after
that I don't think that it really
matters as much as people think it does
[Music]